please welcome the star of stranger than
fiction and sherry baby Maggie
Gyllenhaal
a few weeks ago I had a date with a mob
of magicians we met for the Academy's
scientific and technical awards dinner
to acknowledge its Wizards of Technology
some of them work in CGI some of them
work to restore and conserve film and
some of them are inventing machines and
techniques that I discovered that night
were very very difficult to pronounce
the blue magic densitometer anyone one
of them
the remarkable ray Feeny received the
Academy's highest SciTech honor the
Gordon isaw award an Oscar presented for
his groundbreaking work in camera motion
control and blue screen technology as
well as for his powerful influence in
preserving promoting and advancing the
technologies of the entire motion
picture industry it was a wild night and
I was delighted to be one of the
principal visual effects congratulations
ready
I've done la Ponte I'm Jeana Tuttle and
this is the Oscars
the 79th annual Academy Awards on ABC
brought to you by cat
the best Cadillac stories are live and
shared share yours today on my Cadillac
story dot-com diet coke proud sponsor
the 2007 Academy Awards take your turn
down the red carpet at My Coke Rewards
com JCPenney today's the day to be
inspired
JCPenney every day matters and L'Oreal
Paris proud sponsor of a semi ninth
Academy Awards L'Oreal Paris because
you're worth it